in the 12th century rabbi abraham bar  gia discovered a stunning visualization  of a circle's area  imagine filling the circle with  concentric circles  cut along one radius length and unwrap  the circles into straight line segments  if repeated for infinitely thin line  segments the resulting shape will be a  triangle whose height is r  and base is the circle circumference two  pi r  the triangle's area is then one half  times two pi r times r which simplifies  to be pi r squared  thus the circle's area is pi r squared  incredible  and for the critical viewer the  technique has been rigorously justified  in a 2001 mathematical paper